because I love spreadsheets obviously
because it's a tool for the brain but
like I can't communicate with it it's
impossible and you can't retrofit it you
know it's like I can list a million
reasons why you can't but you just can't
and so I was like oh my God you know we
have a window here to build a data
narrative that actually work so you know
like for your student audience maybe
it's it's useful to understand how our
careers always pan
[Music]
out Nuno job welcome to 20-minute
leaders thank you so much for spending
this time with me how are you I'm good
thanks for having me thank you very much
so you're calling from England today
right that is true I'm calling from fair
in England even though the palm trees or
something make it look otherwise
yeah amazing well well and you know I'm
really excited to dive in with you today
about you know all the context of of
your company desie Pad but but in
general your journey as an entrepreneur
technologist um you've had a lot of
experience doing many many different
things a from the executive level to the
entrepreneurial level to the engineering
level and so a lot of different
experiences that you've accumulated and
um and in this short conversation I'd
love to hear a little bit about your
experience and what you take away from
from your journey leading all the way up
to to desad and looking at the way we
make sense of numbers and business
intelligence and and the world of of of
organized number systems and and uh
obviously this is the world which we as
a society have have made such a critical
part of our of our daytoday you ever
since really I guess the birthing of
Excel or maybe even earlier and so I'm
excited to to hear a little bit about
your vision for this world and and what
opportunities lie there so again thank
you very much for being here yeah thank
you I think it that's it's a great Point
I've I've always been very fascinated by
numbers you know like and we use numbers
a lot in
advertising uh in media in conver ation
we use it to make a point but somehow
through the education system
through how we relate to each other we
we have this Chasm between the numbers
that we love and the mathematics that we
hate almost like that I know it's not
true for everyone my son absolutely
loves mathematics but for both of us you
know it's the numbers that pull us but
that we do not want to reason with uh so
I think that you make a very fair point
on on that disconnect can do you have
some examples of where we may have this
chasms that you're talking about I mean
if if you look like um very recently uh
a great man called Daniel canman passed
that that won the Nobel Prize of
Economics while being a psychologist for
showing exactly this uh the the biases
that we have with numbers and the way
that we use to persuade people uh the
way that we overestimate events uh when
in reality maybe they're just on the
news a lot with anent Statistics uh I
think that there's a lot of examples the
the way is people are so excited to get
a discount but never want to do anything
to calculate how for instance a a saving
can change their lives in 10 years or if
a mortgage buying or renting a house is
important and I come from a humble
background I would say and most of the
friends I have and most of the family I
have doesn't have the luck and the
luxury of the education that I have
and numbers are a big part of it people
don't engage with it because that
there's almost a belief that they are I
don't know not smart enough to to do it
and it's absolutely a fallacy so I feel
like there
is a very big divide in the world with
numbers I know it sounds very conceptual
but there's a very interesting fact
which is if spreadsheets was a language
I know sounds ludicrous um did you know
that it would be the third most spoken
language in the world so be English
Mandarin spreadsheet something else
isn't that
absolutely lunacy and and to think that
that's true and then you think oh but
everyone knows spreadsheet no very well
L people know spreadsheet but everyone
loves numbers but not everyone can
engage with it and I think that's always
been something that is quite Central to
what I have done uh throughout my career
throughout my my life W so so if you had
to then take AP part where really is the
problem here so if everybody loves
numbers yet very few or just the well
off are able to leverage them in
meaningful ways and there are some some
barriers there what what what is in your
experience is is this barrier I think
there's definitely a lot that happens in
the education uh system Michael I know
you're This brilliant student I was not
a brilliant student
uh and the thing that I I I was great at
physics and terrible at
mathematics which is kind of an anote of
itself and I always trug to to engage
without esoteric of a concept it was and
I think most people just don't go past
that barrier ever uh and they just
decide you know maybe I should be a
writer maybe I should be an artist I
just I just can't do this um so I think
it comes from very early on and I think
it just gets reinforced in people and
then we have people that are knowledge
workers feel comfortable with numbers in
one way or another with one tool like
Excel or maybe a different set of tools
uh but no way to really communicate and
that's really the the premise of
desad it's a place where people can
author their knowledge and others can
consume it in a way that when they they
play with a document they can understand
what impact it has in their life in a
way that hopefully inspires them to
become the authors themselves and so it
sounds like you're saying that that
there's so we we have the numbers the we
we exist in a world where numbers are
all around us and and a lot of our
day-to-day is based off of these numbers
that we accumulate and we create the
problem is then the translation of how
do we make meaningful connections out of
those numbers which I guess in the Excel
world would be more the formulas aspect
right yeah it's either static for
instance you apply for a mortgage and
you get a document right and you can see
everything that it is based on one
specific thing uh some times it's a
spreadsheet when it's a spreadsheet it's
a map of someone's brain you know a
spreadsheet is the most scary thing a
person can send us an atachment because
it basically means look it's a download
of my brain H and you just have to to
reason with with that um I think that
that's quite scary and what often
happens is that in the meeting you kind
of need to have the brain person in the
zoom to kind of like give responses you
know validate is this true or false true
or false and yeah one one Trend that we
saw when we started desad was this um
rise of programmatic notebooks like
Jupiter notebooks where people have real
data analyst teams getting insights and
giving it sort of in a document format
but not really because you need to be a
coder to decipher it and to actually
have meaning of it and when we started
Asad that's really what we were thinking
there's a CM between the people that
want to make sense of numbers and often
these people are billage you know that
there's people that have a lot of
knowledge about a business but just
don't engage for all the reasons we said
before and the people that can actually
create this knowledge and and when we
started Desi that's where we were
thinking like we just fought like with
Jupiter notebooks with Excel with all of
this who in their right mind would right
now go and say okay if I need to create
a tool that really helps this would it
be a spreadsheet today you know would it
be like these funky cells with like text
in a corner as a yellow triangle that
you Hoover on and then you read what the
person meant and then you have to track
back references I just don't think
anyone in the world uh would ever start
like that and that was like the starting
point uh for dasad amazing so so walk me
through the I guess the the experience
that you're you're you want your
customers to have so you know let's
maybe even take a use case or or a
situation and then what would be the
experience from C from a consumer
perspective of how they would engage
with this product well right now we have
teams uh that author documents that
allow their clients uh their co-workers
to to very simply engage and understand
how different permutations of their
offering uh could could change how they
experience their product for instance if
you're a solar panel company uh you
might create a proposal that has you
know uh something to split all your
energy on downtime or you might want to
optimize to do just load uh kind of uses
of your energy and you can give that to
your
user that can look through the document
make all those choices and see what's to
return um in in five years as opposed to
have something very very static or for
instance if you're doing an insurance
policy and you want to understand um
very quickly how adding your partner to
the insurance policy can affect your
premium I think right now it's very
difficult because every time you need to
do one of those activities uh you just
have to go in this sales back and
forward uh and with dead that that can
be instantaneous and you can see and
really understand what the client is
more curious about you know oh actually
the client is interested in the discount
more often than not the client is more
interested in seeing what's the
difference between a premium and a non-
premium offering and now that gives Mari
and how much that cost so it almost goes
back to what you said with the with a
mortgage document that somebody would
get this document which would be static
would be very hard to decipher I guess
here is both the fact that it's that
it's interactive and allows it to play
to have a a play with the document so
that until you get that actual to the
bottom Insight which is what's important
there yeah I mean do two examples that
I've seen three that are really
interesting uh I saw a p firm uh send a
whole model to an entrepreneur where the
entrepreneur can see what's the exit
that they get on day one but also based
on the performance of the business how
much you're going to get after uh which
typically is not something that you know
an entrepreneur would just get like a an
email and so that way the entrepreneur
can say oh if I outperform how does this
affect
Etc and I've seen an hedge fund uh that
actually modeled sensitivity analysis
over a stock where they could
go if it was a tech business so like if
the price per developer goes down what
does this mean for the valuation of this
business while at the same go at the
same time playing with the uh Federal
Bank interest rate of the United States
was like you know if the Fed rate goes
down and the price the wages go up what
happens and all for a hedge fund maybe
they normally have like a data team
doing that and they could just you know
slide a little bit and have a a
discussion not about the data but a
discussion about the decision that they
have to make should we or we not
investment this come and so how do you
measure your success here there's
obviously the way that you know startups
measure their success in terms of you
know engagement and and the different a
metrics but I'm curious from a product
perspective how do you because you're
also very driven by a shift in consumer
Behavior or providing a new found
experience how do you then think through
how to assess yourself on whether you're
actually moving towards your vision for
a new reality here it's a really
complicated balances complicated balance
in products of this nature uh I've
spoken with plenty of Founders that both
very early on just made the decision of
going you know we live by the client our
clients are CFOs at companies between
200 and 500 so we're going to build a
fpna tool just for those consumers and
it's going to always work with these gu
Grails and that's our product and I also
spoke with bunch of Founders that do no
we're going to build the foundation the
the Baseline of what this product is and
then we're going to find the beach head
that we're going to explore and we're
going to go in a more horizontal manner
the horizontal versus vertical both the
founders I'm thinking about I don't want
to quote them because I don't want to
put them on the spot are very very
successful and build like you know uh
multi-billion dollar
businesses um for desad we definitely
thought that for us to achieve our
mission or helping people have a better
relationship with numbers we needed to
go horizontal first now going horizontal
first is I think I'm sure that the other
people would say the opposite but it's
like the most difficult journe because
as you say like it's much easier to have
metrics when you have a very concrete go
to market and you are focused on a
single person person and a single
problem to solve as opposed to here is
my
tool now let me find this speach head
that really
works uh but for the mission and for
what I've been working all my career it
just it only made sense to try to change
the consumer Behavior too that's what I
wanted to do to give a tool that allows
consumers to engage with numbers all
very very nice tell me a little bit
about the company the formation where
you're at today yeah I know I think I
mean that a lot of your audiences is
maybe students maybe they're thinking or
uh doing a startup um and if you're not
I apologize but I'm mostly going to
speak to the students because I was one
myself um I I was a computer science uh
student
and I didn't really think much of
Entrepreneurship maybe because I didn't
even know what the word meant um and it
only when I went to New York I really
opened my eyes to to this as a reality I
worked mostly in databases and in
document
databases and it it was really
interesting to see because document
databases unlike relational database now
now they're popular with the term no
sequel that showed up like around 2012
2013 maybe earlier 2008 I don't remember
but um document database were a very
Niche thing and Publishers needed to
integrate all these documents and I I
saw the need to make sense of these
relations between numbers and long St
documents mostly financial services from
what I was on those
days um but it was it's so difficult you
know like you need a database expert you
need an app uh expert
um and I I went through my career kind
of hopping through database in New York
in IBM to San Francisco and Mark logic
and I was always seeing people with this
kind of problems and they were really
excited about using documents more but
we live in a world that is for apps you
know it's relational database and apps
and documents are which I always found
it was ludicrous because most of us live
95% of our time in documents uh not in
apps but somehow the whole ecosystem is
built around apps and relations and not
like this context that I
have so for your students listening you
know that that was kind of like it
wasn't I'm going to start a company one
day I kind of like went through my
interest areas which I think remain the
same today and always through the
passion that I had for the topics that I
loved um back when I was in in San
Francisco I met a couple of people that
were building this new technology called
node.js so I decided to move away this
small small new technology in the in the
background yeah I mean it it was it was
I I remember talking to to Ryan like the
first time I met him and he he thought
that I went to a FY University because I
knew functional programming and I
realized that the United States really
has a gap there um but I remember
telling him like JavaScript in the
server right you stupid you sound like a
smart man um but him and a bunch more
people were really motivated to create
this technology and I thought it was
really exciting I started writing
programs in it and I I created this
company in in New York City called
created I mean I I was hired by the
founders became one of the executives um
that um was the original no JS platform
with a service you that quite a big
footprint it got sold to go. in but I I
was still in the same path you know
before was do in databases and I was
helping developers deliver these
experiences so I just felt like the
database you know there's a lot of no
SQL databases like mongodb and cdb and
can deliver these these really simple
apps that unlike Java we just like you
know turn key seven lines of code and
you can do do something useful without
being like miserable for 40 minutes
while
deployed and that was really really like
a great time and you know
as a student I I I look back and like I
was still like from intern to full-time
employee almost um I still look back at
at those times as some of the times that
I work the hardest and that I learned
the most um then I I moved to
London in because building no Jitsu was
well it's always complicated when you
build a business I didn't want to use
Venture Capital again uh because I got a
little bit burned there
uh nothing wrong with it but different
businesses require different things I
kind of serendipit started a
consultancy I by now I had lots of
experience working with consume with
clients and clients and I've always been
a big fan of McKenzie which I know is
not something very popular but the
original McKenzie so I thought like I'll
build a Consulting um software
engineering like you know the they their
their Consultants like what if software
was a top level thing at uh
at like the executive level um and yeah
I I bootstrap that business from you
know zero to about $20 million it it's
still a family-owned business quote
unquote um and once again now I had two
parts of me that wanted to use this sort
of software one was obviously I needed
to give reports to clients I needed to
do calculations which I just did in
spreadsheets and like you know send them
the down of my brain good ridd to them
and the other one was I started as the
business scaled very rapidly I figured
out that that was a massive Gap in
software it's like when you start you're
kind of doing everything you go to 30
people you're kind of doing everything
and and then you need you you maybe you
install zero or QuickBooks and you're
kind of okay you outsourced to NFD
you're okay but then you're a 50 or 60
and all of a sudden people are banging
on your door with crms erps all of this
crap and and all you've built is this
beautiful network of people that like
working together and are really nice and
smart and they deliver and some guy is
telling you to install this Erp that
they use to sell shoes or in North
America or in Asia I'm like I couldn't
care less this is you know like oh for a
fee of
$40,000 we'll install it and you can I'm
like so I actually started like building
a bunch of Google Sheets that integrated
with like JavaScript and we had like a
team of like five engineers at once like
just doing this because I was as an as
someone scaling a company I was like I
do not want to use these Enterprise
softwares you know like I feel like that
software was built for the Auditors like
you you're going to be audited you're
big enough okay you have to pay for the
software but no I just wanted skills you
know I wanted to give people the freedom
to have an operative system and once
again that went that took me straight up
to what Desa did the funny thing is
through throughout all of this my career
and I think for for most of your
listeners like I I never cared about
being a leader I actually always found
it a bit uncomfortable to be perfectly
honest I love helping people I don't
like telling people what to do
necessarily um I never focused on money
um like you know even companies that I
advised that went on to be very
successful I did it like for nothing and
luckily enough people tend giving me
something back um and I always kind of
follow the same path of the passions
that I always had in one way or the
other and I never thought of
profiteering from it you know like even
though this was like throughout my
career um something I was just like ah
well whatever you know it's like I'm not
going to do something about it unless
there's something to do then Co came and
I took some time off um by that time A
friend of mine uh which I helped from
very early on to like an exit called
rovski had sold his company uh which was
a big exit for me personally because I
was I think one of probably the first
person to give that company money I I do
a lot of Angel Investments I'm very
proud of them they're great companies if
anyone wants to check I'm sure you can
share the link but I was I had an exit
there wildy was a fairly established
business so I had no requirements so in
Co I was really thinking what to do next
um and it was that finally then that I I
got up to this idea um even though it's
been building all of these years I I was
like one thing that aggravated me in the
consultancy I've done lots of digital
transformation projects like you know
the new fogue or you know I shouldn't
list or the new Economist but um when
when you you do all those projects one
thing that I started noticing in the
late years to 2019 20120 was everyone
talking about Ai and me I started
machine learning in cryptography
in school so everyone talking about
cryptocurrencies in AI really got me
freaked out because I thought it was
like these far-fetched mathematical
things I had studied um so when covid
came I decided to study it a bit kind of
do a recap and I actually did a great
course from Stanford called CS
321n uh I didn't pay for it I just did
the GitHub thing and that's deepal
networks yeah yeah yeah and I I it blew
me away that I did everything in a
Jupiter notebook with no students uh
like friends with no teacher nothing I
just went there and wrote some stuff and
I got I mean I probably don't know
anything but you know I felt like I
learned something or or at least recap
my knowledge
and maybe that's when I did the worst
turn in my life because I could have
focused entirely on AI and I focused
entirely on the document I was like this
is the gap that I've been looking for
you can build a data narrative with
these numbers I don't don't have to like
go back to that spreadsheet and have to
communicate there because I love
spreadsheets obviously because you're a
tool for the break but like I can't
communicate with that it's impossible
and you can't retrofit it you know it's
like I can list a million reasons why
you can't but just can't and so I was
like oh my God you know we have a window
here to build a data narrative that
actually works so you know like for I I
think like for for your your your
student audience Maybe it's useful to
understand how our careers always pan
out it's incredible yeah I mean I'm very
thankful for all the mentors I had and
all the people I'm meeting one of them
today that really gave me the
opportunity to step up working with
Incredible people was a big part of this
but but I I always find it inspiring
when I talk to people growing up and I
see like this big smile that is
connected by one single topic that they
just love being good at and they just
keep doing it and it can take you many
different ways but it's normally people
that are very happy no no this is a
fascinating I wrote so much for myself
over the over especially over the last
10 minutes or so this is what a journey
and uh something that I think every
every entrepreneur should hear so thank
you very very much for sharing this with
me and I want to thank you for coming on
this uh on this show and this this
program I really appreciate it and
wishing you best of luck with Dy pad and
everything that you're doing and I'm
excited to use a prod of myself so thank
you very much for the inspiration thank
you and by the way if any of the
listeners uh needs anything feel free to
shend me an email I'm very easy to find
and I'm always happy to help thank you
so much